[Music]
well we're sitting here and very happy
to be with Ashley reisenberger is that
did I pronounce that correctly reenberg
recently you've became re for I'm a
recent Burger
yes absolutely we're just married in
December so very exciting time so your
husband Tim reenberg I'm sure a lot of
people are very familiar with him
absolutely yeah he's been preaching and
sharing for many years traveling and he
married somebody who has almost never
traveled anywhere so now I get to come
along on all the adventures so tell us a
little bit about your background where
you come from so I actually grew up in
the world of Show
Business and in mostly a non-Christian
home my mother came from somewhat of an
Adventist background but never got
baptized uh because of a lot of
discouraging circumstances in her life
people said oh you're not ready to get
baptized and so she just never did um
then my dad is actually Mormon and so
because my mom and dad couldn't agree on
anything spiritually us kids didn't
really have a religious experience
growing up and so I kind of just grew up
and theater was my thing that I was
involved in from the time I was in
kindergarten all the way until I was 18
uh but my brother actually went to some
Revelation seminars by Shan bura and
that changed his life and he decided to
give his life to Jesus Christ and since
that point he started to really pray for
our family and reach out to us and share
tracks which was very unwelcome to me at
the time because I was steeped in the
world and what is this you want me to
stop doing my shows on Friday night and
Saturday it was very much not something
I wanted to hear but something I needed
to hear at the time and even even though
it was unwelcome it did convict my heart
um because I would call myself
throughout all those years somebody who
believed in God but I was somebody who
believed in God who left my Bible
sitting on the Shelf getting Dusty and
didn't read it and your career was just
beginning to take off right it was by
the time I was 18 I had offers to sing
in the Santa Fe Opera to to join their
vocal performance program in New Mexico
State University to join theatrical
performances in multiple areas but at
that time I decided to walk away from
everything wow and it's because
something very big happened in my life
so how how did you decide to because
that's a very big step and that at that
age everything that you get taught is
you have to believe in yourself and you
can be somebody and all of this and now
you decided no absolutely it's true it
it is a big turning point in life when
you're 18 and you feel like the entire
world is open to you and it's because
God was really convicting my heart
through different things that were
happening to me at the time I remember I
was uh supposed to go on a date with a
young man to the state fair and uh he
stood me up but I ended up taking my
parents instead and as we
were we ended up leaving the state fair
and um somebody was giving out DVDs of
total
Onslaught and uh and you were all how
old then I was 16 16 16 and so my mom
and I went home home and put it in the
DVD player and watched and watched and
could not stop watching and I remember
thinking wow I just feel like my life is
turning upside down because it's finally
all of my
questions where science and history and
theology merged together could be
answered I remember my professors
throughout all the years telling me you
can believe in evolution and the Bible
at the same time you can believe in
evolution and creation at the same time
and trying to convince me those two
ideas could be merged merged together
and be harmonious theistic Evolution
yeah exactly and all through college
actually even my professors tried to
convince me that but thankfully I had
known better after seeing those
presentations and that really made me
think a lot about what I had been taught
my entire life and I wanted to know okay
I could see evidence that God created
the world what kind of a person is he
and that is really what changed my life
is to see that God is love and that he
doesn't want to beat me over the head
and force me to do anything that I don't
want to do that all of his laws are
lifegiving and they are meant to do me
good and um I just praise God because
that helped me to really discover my
true identity because as somebody who
grew up in Show Business I was
constantly playing other characters all
the time and um as I learned more about
secret society ities and some of the
things that they do I could actually see
hints of that in my own theater
experience we had a lot of rituals that
we would engage in before performances
we would for instance all all of us
would stand in a circle and hold hands
we would have a moment of silence before
we started every performance and some of
my directors would even say things like
you can tray to the theater Gods now if
you would perform or who whoever you
would like to talk to during this time
and I remember um was a very new age
sort of introduction it was a very new
age sort of experience and I could see
how there were a lot of um those new age
Elements Incorporated into the theater
it's just interesting that a lot of
people don't realize how much religion
is involved in
Chas absolutely there is a lot of
religion in that I mean that we were
even told things like you can't say the
word MC Beth or else you're going to
curse the show wow so there's a lot of
superstition and things like that
involved and I could see that a lot more
clearly once I took a step away from it
and really started to open the word of
God and and learn history and learn
what's actually happening behind the
scenes with the powers that be in this
world and I could see that all of this
that I was seeking in my life was worth
nothing and a life with Jesus Christ was
worth everything so you and your mom
actually watched it together yes we did
and did did that change her from a more
nominal uh association with the
Adventist to a more serious one praise
God it did we both had such conviction
after that happened I actually was the
first between my mom and I to start
going back to church and I said Mom
you've got to come and hear the messages
that I'm hearing here and she had a lot
of fear because of the bad experiences
she had had before and I said Mom it's
not about the people it's not about the
C ances it's about Jesus Christ it's
about your relationship with him and she
said okay I'll go with you and so we
were baptized together uh 10 years ago
this year 10 years oh wow so I praise
God that my mom is now a part of the
faith my oldest brother as well and I
have two other brothers and my father
that we are praying for as well course
yeah never stopped I understand your
father is sick yes he needs prayer amen
yes my father he was diagnosed with
cancer uh last year but praise God he's
been a lot more spiritually open since
then we've had prayer and family worship
for the first time in my entire life and
some people wouldn't believe that uh
when we my husband came over and had
family worship my oldest brother was
sitting there just in complete disbelief
because we never had that experience
growing up and it's really just I can
see how God answers prayer and the the
answer really is to continue praying for
those who are outside of the faith
because you never know what God can use
to reach them so how did you meet them
you know interestingly you know I had
had a bad breakup when I was just brand
new to the faith and somebody in church
who's been a mentor to me said you know
what what can heal you from this is just
go ahead first into Ministry give your
life more wholeheartedly to Jesus Christ
than you ever have before and Just
Surrender everything to him and use the
talents that he has given you to serve
him because I had been in show business
all these years and God has given me
these talents for a reason and I said
okay I wanted to use these talents to
serve him and to do something better
with that instead of serving the enemy
and so I started getting involved in
music Ministry with my brother who plays
piano and i' would be singing for church
services for camp meetings for weddings
funerals that was very fulfilling for me
and then getting a lot more involved in
other things in Ministry that I never
ever thought I'd be doing one of the
things that sitting here today and
getting interviewed by you today but um
I am so grateful for that advice because
she said while you are in the path of
ministry you may look beside you and see
somebody who has the same passion for
the Lord as you do and who's going the
same direction that's exactly what
happened uh five six years after that
Tim came into my life as we are both on
a group that is geared toward evangelism
it's called Evangel living on Facebook
and uh we connected initially through
that and then continue talking and
growing a relationship together and the
rest is history now we get to do
evangelism together it's such a
beautiful wonderful what all right can
you tell me what advice do you have to
the young people out there with regard
to music and what you consider to be
divinely inspired music and what do you
from your background consider to be
something that might even take you away
from God yes I you know
I think a lot of even really sincere
people are trying to use methods that
the devil uses to draw people in y and
even though I believe that they're very
sincere I don't think that it's safe to
use methods that the devil is using um
and one of the challenges to that is you
know okay say that we make some
Christian rap or Christian rock music or
Christian heavy metal it's hard to even
imagine those two things together and
then somebody gets drawn into church
what are they going to think when in
church we say yeah that's not of God
have to create a church where those that
music is played so that people can and
then there's a continual compromise and
that's really the message that I would
give to young people is do not
compromise for anything Jesus Christ
never compromised the truth he never
compromised
principle uh he was always true to the
Bible he was always true to God his
father and we must choose to do the same
thing we can't compromise with the ways
of the world and that's really what I
had to learn the hard way is because I
grew up with all of those things that
were compromising and I was being told
that it's okay to merge these two things
together but they do not belong together
and that's really the lesson that you
read from all of scripture is God's
people continue to compromise with the
things that were not of God and the
methods that are not of God but God is
saying don't worship me that way that's
not the way I operate when you can see
these elements of force and coercion and
um other worldly elements you can see
that that's not God's character so
that's my biggest message to young
people is to stay true to the Bible the
spirit of Prophecy stay true to God do
not
compromise yes that's a very important
point do not compromise you know if
music is
done with a spirit of total
commitment it's very uplifting it be
very beautiful amen true the music we
heard today was it uplifting or was it
not you know the music I hear today
scares me a little bit and I think a
good way to test music is look at
Philippians 4:8 right that can give us a
good guideline for if something is
actually in line with God's word so um I
think we're looking for music that's
going to be reverential it's going to be
respectful to God and it's not going to
give us you know sadly a lot of the
music out there is very sensual and it
it brings forth feelings that I don't
want to feel in church there's a proper
time and place for a married couple
right to feel those feelings but there's
music being played on the radio I mean
even when we were in the car yesterday
you could hear the the car next to us
blurring this music that's not uh you
know some churches are playing music
like that in church so what are the
plans for the future for your life
together you know uh we get asked that
question a lot and I say I just leave it
completely in the Lord's hands
and I just think of how Jesus just
allowed God to un unfold his plans day
by day and Moment by moment which my
husband would say that's very hard for
me as somebody who just thrives on
checklists and uh you know making sure
that my day is scheduled exactly the way
that I would like it to but you know
what my favorite days are the days that
don't go exactly according to the way I
was planning and go the way that God was
planning because then we have the
opportunity to reach out to people
around us and share the good news that
Jesus Christ loves them and he desires
to live with them forever that's true so
now that you've sort of separated
yourself from your old world do you miss
it or do you feel fulfilled in what you
are doing now I can tell you that I feel
100% contentment and fulfillment from
what I'm doing now but I do have a
burden for the
friends that I used to have that are
still stuck in that world and still
seeking the things of the world to fill
the god-shaped hole in their heart that
only God can fill and and that is why I
think it's important for me to share uh
this message with with young people so
that hopefully they can hear that as
well that I have found peace that I
never found in the world and there is
peace perfect peace in Jesus Christ and
relationship with him Have you shared
total Onslaught with those friends of
yours you know I've shared online but I
haven't shareed in a more formal way I
probably should thank you for
encouraging
me I think it is definitely that's one
of the things because we want to try and
Empower people that's the thing
partnership is is the only way we can
get this message out to everybody else
and Partnerships means just sending a
message out just encouraging I mean the
way you got it was just by somebody
passing it on yes I just spoke to a lady
just now who comes from the new age
world she is brand new into this and uh
it's so encouraging
and sometimes we're afraid to to share
something that you know seems a little
bit radical compared to where they are
at that particular time but some people
just need that little extra shock that's
so true and that's what I really
appreciate about Clash of Minds because
you're not afraid to talk about what's
deemed controversial to a lot of people
today but somebody needs to talk about
these things even though it's being seen
as controversial because there are a lot
of things happening right now that our
fulfillment of Prophecy and the world
has questions what does this mean for us
and what does the future hold exactly we
have to have an answer it was wonderful
to be able to speak to you and thank you
for taking the time to to meet with us
thank you so much for having me thank
you have you got a last word of
encouragement for your friends and ex
colleagues out there I would
say I know that you're seeking for peace
and contentment and I know you're
seeking for love and the greatest love
I've ever found is in the Lord Jesus
Christ and I would encourage those who
are
skeptical to be open-minded and to
actually read the word and ask for the
holy spirit to guide you as you read so
that you can have understanding of who
God truly is because the devil tries to
paint God as this monster as a sadistic
person who just wants to hurt you to
destroy you but that's actually what the
devil is about that's not what God is
about and I truly believe that we can
see a picture of God that's very
different from that in scripture and
he in the very end will vindicate his
character before all of the universe and
all will see and I just pray for all my
friends and all my family and all that
we're connected with that they will be
on the right side of those Gates when
Jesus comes ien you are absolutely right
the very last sermons to be preached
will be preached on the the character of
God and they will vindicate the
character of God Amen thank you for
speaking would you mind praying for us
yes Heavenly
Father what a beautiful story when
people as
young as we are witnessing here right
before us decide to follow you and
follow you with your whole with their
whole heart and with their whole mind I
pray that you will bless the reasenberg
is in their Ministry in their walk
together in their life together and may
they reach many and turn them to
righteousness is my prayer in Jesus name
amen amen amen Tim how you doing
excellent Robert how are you good thanks
wonderful it's nice to have you here and
uh on a Sabbath day he here at the ASI
it's really awesome to be here couldn't
be better yeah we had a great lunch
together right vegan thae what a spread
yes and um yeah thanks for taking the
time uh to speak with us we would like
to yeah we would like to know a little
bit more about you and uh your
missionary work and everything that you
you have done and how you couple this
with the work that you do and uh yeah I
think we should we should dig in a
little bit deeper and see see how we can
get some information out yeah that
sounds great so yeah we can start off by
what do you do for a living well I'm an
Emergency Physician I I went to medical
school at lomalinda graduated at
Stanford University for my residency I
also did my Master's in public health in
preventive medicine at the adventus
University in Mexico Monto Morelos wow
and I use those as my tent making
opportunity so I work about 6 to 8 days
a month roughly uh sometimes less
sometimes more but never more than 8
Days uh but these are 12-hour shifts
yeah and so it's can be a long day uh
but with my danco clogs I can stay on my
feet uh for that length without back
pain and it's a blessing because when
people are in an
emergency nobody's atheist anymore they
all believe in God they don't cry out to
Natural Selection when they're going to
die they don't cry out to Buddha they
cry out to God so people are very open I
often get a chance to pray with others
and point them to the great physician
where where do you operate with your
operation well I do what's called looms
which is travel Physicians so I try to
find hospitals that are very short right
now I'm working at a small community
hospital in rural Kentucky but I'm just
about getting ready to start at a
hospital in Illinois where I was
actually born in ironically enough oh so
we're looking forward to that great
going back to the roots exactly the
Midwest uh so if you only work 8 days a
month what do you do the rest of the
time well Ashley and I have made a
commitment and this was a promise I made
while I was at Stanford I said Lord when
I graduate with my education I will
dedicate at one thing like it can be
anything it can be medical trip it could
be a week of prayer it could be a health
Revival we could be Evangelistic
campaign but we'll do one thing every
month to your honor and glory and
without pay now since then I've always
had something every month if you can
believe it and on average we we get
about 100 to 140 decisions for baptism
every year so we're very thankful for
that wow that's quite a lot and how how
did uh um when did you come into the
faith well I came into the faith through
my father my dad was invited by a friend
to a Daniel and Revelation seminar by
dick Pard one of the old oldtime
evangelists and my parents had gone
through a divorce at that time but I was
still visiting my dad on the weekend so
he said hey would you like to attend
this little seminar while you're here on
Saturday and Sunday and I said
absolutely so that's what got the ball
rolling but I wasn't completely
converted until I was a junior or third
year in College it was through a book
written by an Adventist woman but not
surprisingly Ellen White okay by
Margaret Davis perhaps you know her the
book is called what shall I do to be
saved yes wow nice okay so must have
been I know for myself it was quite
tough during those time I mean you were
probably around 22 23 years old well I
was a junior I was 19 I graduated
University at 20 and then my masters at
21 so I was a little bit further
advanced than average so wasn't it tough
I mean you had a lot of I guess peer
pressure a lot of friends in the world
yes yes yes my family was was not my
mother my brother my sister were not
Adventists at that time and so I was
struggling when I came home from this
decision from college but what am I
going to do everyone eats meat how am I
going to stick to the vegan diet how am
I going to hold faithful and God just
impressed me just minister to them and
so I told my mom every vacation I'll
take care of all the meals wow I had
done cooking classes I had done the New
Start programs there at wear and so I
thought why not and she said wow that
would be such a relief I don't have to
come home from work and cook cuz you got
it all taken care of and then I was able
to of course stick with the vegan diet
at the same time w wow so did you adopt
all of these truths at once not at once
I I took a little while I was vegetarian
for a while initially uh and then I
transitioned completely and and I would
say it took a while with things like
entertainment you know that's always a
struggle for young people do you do you
continue to go to the movies with your
friends yes right do you do you continue
uh reading things do you continue
listening things do you continue
participating in certain types of sports
and activities but it did take a while I
would say probably 3 years for those
things to go away and amazingly it took
my sister when she had her conversion
experience I had always enjoyed playing
cards not for gambling or for money but
i' always enjoyed playing cards with my
grandparents because cuz they lived with
me for about 15 years until my sister
was converted and she gave up all card
playing wow and my grandfather C says
you know she won't play cards with us
anymore now and I said I think I need to
do the same and he went wow cuz I of
course had been Adventist longer than
anyone yeah yeah so when so you became
Adventist at that age of 20 and your
family wasn't they were not no I visited
my grandfather and my grandmother in
Florida every summer just during
vacation and things like that from
school and I just asked them I said just
promise me one thing that you and
grandpa will read the Bible together
every day and they said we promise we
believe in the Bible they were devout
Catholics and so my grandmother was
first as a senior citizen she made a
decision for baptism and Grandpa ah he's
going to live Catholic and die Catholic
so he didn't want to go to church but
she kept going but then at one point she
stopped and I said Grandma why have you
stopped going she says well grandpa
doesn't want to go and I said but do you
love the Lord more or do you love
Grandpa more she's like of course the
Lord and then she says I'm going to go
back and then he started coming with her
now he wasn't baptized but when he lived
with me he went to church with us every
Sabbath Faithfully a week before he died
he quit drinking alcohol he was very
tender and sweet to Grandma and at the
end of that week he was found dead in
his sleep but when I went out to his
easy chair I found an Open Bible right
at its side and I knew what he was doing
right before he died so I couldn't ask
for God to give a better end to my
grandfather's mortal life knowing that
he would have amazing that's a good
relief and yeah wow and when we Chang to
being from eating meat to being a vegan
a lot of people come to us and they say
but there's no protein in your diet you
can't get protein from plants and
everything so being a doctor do you have
that same questions or all the time
opposition all the time but for me I
have the opposite because I work out
with uh guys who are average age 18 to
25 and they'll say well wait a minute
you're turning 50 this month how is it
you can keep up with this I said well
you know I have a little different
program and they say are you on the
juice which means steroids of course or
beta HCG or human growth hormone
something like I said I don't use any of
that stuff I actually eat this way they
said there's no way so the proof is in
the pudding yes absolutely I'm about 92
kg I'm very strong very solid fit I can
do I actually did the booth there by
Heartland they said if you can do uh is
it 10 pull-ups or 15 dips we'll give you
a t-shirt I did both wow so I was happy
to win my t-shirts for my wife of course
wow and if you if you take it back to
Daniel I mean that was the case with a
absolutely with the three friends as
well the proof was in that 10 days yeah
definitely so just back to the the
previous uh story quickly uh did you
play a big part in your in your family's
conversion to 7 adventism when my
grandmother and my grandfather uh were
kind of wondering about this new
decision I had made I recorded
personally the book steps to Christ by
my reading it and I gave it to every
member of my family and of course
Grandma and Grandpa they love to hear
their grandkids voice and my grandfather
was a radio announcer for many years so
he's big into media and stuff like that
so they enjoyed that and they said that
did play a big role uh my sister however
I was gone doing a week of prayer
in our Academy in Finland in toy and
when I came back I came back to a
message cuz I didn't have a reception on
my phone when I when I was Landing I got
this message from my sister who had
previously been an Atheist and uh she
says hey when you get back uh I'm
wondering if you could spend some time
teaching me how to pray and study the
Bible and so of course I went right up
to Seattle where she lived I drove
immediately up there and we studied
until midnight she was on her knees
weeping giving her heart to Jesus Christ
wow and then after that she went and
became a missionary in Thailand for
seven years and she's still a faithful
Adventist to this day doesn't happen a
lot no where everyone just accepts the
truth yes my older brother is the last
one of our F immediate family that has
not made that decision so Steve this is
for you and your family we love you oh
that's amazing and you know what I found
when I was struggling uh when I was
around 21 I gave my life to the Lord but
but not entirely and because of that I
fell back into the into the world but
the main reason was because of sheer
isolation yes so so I want to know from
you how what can you tell other people
out there how can you overcome isolation
because that was a fear that I had and
that's why that's why I chose friends
over the Lord and it's really sad but
yeah you and I are very similar and we
learned this in the pandemic as a
physician I can tell you the literature
is very clear now that isolation is
equivalent to smoking a pack of
cigarettes every day that's how damaging
it is to your health loneliness and
isolation are one of the big risk
factors now and we found that social
connection is vital for Recovery of
health and the way I tell people that
that happens is if you feel isolated you
can reach out to someone else who's
worse off than you and that that for me
has been tremendous every time I've
either gone away to school school or
I've bought a house and lived somewhere
I've always invited people to be
roommates people who maybe need a little
bit of break on the rent or something
like that a family that's kind of
displaced you know and so you always
have someone there and it's as you are a
blessing to others that you are actually
more blessed and so I would just tell my
friends the best way to overcome
isolation is to minister to someone who
who you know is much worse off than you
are and if you have a bad group then
create another peer group convert your
friends have Bible studies with your
friends I was just telling uh Ashley my
wife we really are excited we have a
Bible study group every week that meets
with non-believers we have about four
people that are interested right now to
come regularly and it's absolutely
fantastic because the law of life is to
give is to live God designed us to do
that and he's designed us to be social
creatures we cannot be alone the Bible
says no one one lives to himself no one
dies to himself we're not an island as
The Poets have said we have to engage
with others in Fellowship that's
meaningful yeah like I believe what we
did on Friday and just fellowshipping
with each other for about four or five
hours that is one of the most healing
remedies that you can have because you
have like-minded Brethren you're having
uh Sabbath worship together you're
singing songs together you're talking
about Ministry together you're enjoying
one another's company and that is what
God designed us for Fellowship but
positive Fellowship so I use peer
pressure to my advantage I try to
surround myself in the core group of
people that are very committed so that
when I'm around the non-believers I've
been fortified I've been energized I've
been plugged in through that devotion
and also that Fellowship from my mates
to stand strong for the right that's
very clear and and what I take from that
is we need to stand firm for truth you
know and and that's maybe something at
that age that I didn't have and and we
need to be an example instead of
engaging in sin with them and trying to
get them out of that we we we cannot do
that without being really strong in our
faith so we we need to be an example and
we need to try and convert them
absolutely way we are either a
missionary or a mission field yeah one
of the two you either growing or you are
dying just like nature teaches us if
that water doesn't move it breeds
corruption that's correct and that's the
same thing with us the only only way to
ensure a fire goes out is don't let it
spread y that's the key that's great and
speaking about not being alone speaking
about isolation you recently got married
yes to an ex-actress as well yes yes
about it my wife was a paid actress from
age8 she was involved with producers
like Dale waserman who did one flu over
the cuckoo nest Big Time Players in this
industry and she was a child actress
paid professionally from age8 through
her teen years and you've probably heard
of the Tony Awards and things like that
she was winning local awards called the
Arizon at the time she was confronted
with Jesus Christ she had to make a
decision she had multiple offers in
different Broadway sort of type shows
theater and she had a permanent position
offered her at the Santa Fe Opera and
she encountered a DVD which made her
walk away from all of you encounter this
well she actually had a date with a guy
thank God she didn't marry him thank you
Jesus she had a date with a guy at the
state fair and he stood her up and so
she was very indignant but said well I
might as well enjoy the the fair with my
mother here so she went around the fair
the different booths and there was a
young man who was giving out some DVDs
and it was called total onsl there we go
sounds she took it yes in fact you may
know that uh Dr Walter feight is the
producer of that series that's and she
took it home with her mother and they
watched the entire series nonstop hardly
pausing for rest or food or water they
couldn't even sleep they had to finish
the whole thing wow a lot of people
think it's quite a technical series you
know it's quite difficult to grasp at
times but but if you if you searching
for truth you'll manage yes she was 16
she was young when she did that and she
made the decision finally at 18 to walk
away from acting and the theater forever
that is inspiring because it's it's
tough it's tough to walk away from
success on Earth absolutely she was at
the top of her game yeah yes and and
that how does how does your story link
with Clash of Minds well absolutely I I
can say this is that I have been a fan
of clash of Minds for many many years
obviously my wife being converted as a
result of your ministry has endeared you
even more to me but I've enjoyed
actually sharing not only uh the message
that you guys share but enjoying the
what's up Prof series and even speaking
with Dr feight at venues we we spoke
together at University of Maryland as
you're probably aware many years ago we
even did a question and answer session
together for the students in the
audience there so I've not only enjoyed
your ministry but I've worked together
with it uh at at times and if we' we've
collaborated with similar type
Ministries and when he was working with
amazing discoveries he would finish
recording I would come into the Studio
later and so we always were kind of
following each others or whatever but I
can say that what the most important
thing is is that there's one spirit in
our two Ministries we may do different
approaches but the same God is directing
us both y that's correct and and how did
you meet Ashley uh I met Ashley on a
website called Evangel living Dr Calvin
Kim a dentist who actually ran Army
Bible camp and also now F5 challenge he
was actually putting up this website on
Facebook a group and we were all
deciding what are we going to do for
Halloween so she asked the question what
is everyone doing for Halloween and what
I do is I get all the really high-end
vegan goodies like The Cliff Bars the
Builder bars the larab bars cans of nuts
things like that high-end vegan goodies
but I also get all of the spooky themed
Bible studies from either amazing facts
or glow or things like that what happens
when you die is the devil in charge of
Hell Twilight trick or treat from Steven
Walberg so we enjoy all those but you
present it or do you just hand it out I
just I hand it out to people I say in
one of these tracks is a crisp $100 bill
and you're welcome to have one but you
must read it and you must share it but
ironically enough in the last 7 years no
one has ever gotten the $100 bill even
though I placed the $100 bill in the top
track right next to them when they have
the tra so it's right in front of them
but they'll usually go to the back right
corner go down three and then they'll
slip one out from underneath they
overthink it just like all of us
salvation is right in front of us but we
try to look for it in such strange ways
yeah wow that's that's interesting so so
what's your secret when you when you
blend your the work that you do in the
health sector and the the missionary
side I mean what how do you how do you
juggle that and what is your secret to
to elevated it my secret get it out
there is an acronym called eternal life
each one of those letters stands for one
of the re remedies outlined in
inspiration and I can tell you that I
have discovered my three power areas in
the natural remedies and they're not
what you would imagine uh we have a
Ministry called only longevity. RG and
don't worry if you go to com.net We own
them all so it's only longevity and we
teach people how to reverse the aging
process and I am turning 50 years old
this month and I can tell you my gray
hairs are all turning black jet black
again and my hair is so full it's it's
Fuller than it's ever been I'm like I
don't know if you remember the pet back
in the '90s called chiaia pet but they
spread these chia seeds on this pottery
and it just Sprouts it's absolutely
amazing what what what has done to my
hair but I I the secret is is eternal
life and only longevity. RG we we follow
these remedies that many people do not
use in Inspiration what an interesting
thing that it said uh when you look at
uh the commentary of an inspired writer
named Ellen White she says virtue comma
the healing power of love was an all
Christ M Miracles but how many
Ministries use love as a remedy but I
found that that is the number one way
that I've reversed my age because when I
look at a hair that's gone from Gray to
Black I can measure exactly where it
happened because my hair grows about 1
and 1/2 2 cm a month so I can actually
calculate when the hair transition from
Gray to Black and 80% of those hairs I
can date Back to December 3rd w wow our
wedding day so for me love is the remedy
and spreading it and exactly and that's
the third remedy the second remedy I
found when I've actually met long lost
relatives that I've never met in my
entire life when I encounter them I
connect with them we fellowship with
them that's the second most common
reason for my hairs to turn from Gray to
Black about 15% of them are from the
fellowship just like you talked about
being with people you love and care
about about
5% is election which is your calling
what doing what God has called you to do
when I when I did a campaign in
Amsterdam for the Youth we had about 25
decisions for baptism I saw several
hairs transition from Gray to Black at
that date so those are the three top
areas for secret for me but for some
people it might be nutrition other
people it might be rest and everyone has
their power area everyone has their weak
point also so we teach people how to
strengthen their weak point and
capitalize on their power areas I must
say you know I'm I'm definitely going to
going to ask you for some tips because
I'm also I've I've been struggling with
with my with my hair and to and since I
was 25 I mean I had a lot of stress at a
young age and that I was I probably have
more hair now than I did when I was
about 25 so it's going the right
it's going the right direction but I
could could do I'm doing something wrong
you know so I would love to pick your
brain on that you know after the show
maybe I tell people this is the body
doesn't lie it's as you said the proof
is in the pudding your body will speak
to you and I'll give you another hint
your body will give you check engine
lights and your check engine light is
different than yours is different than
mine I'll give you one of mine I have a
little lymph node right here right under
my chin called the digastric node it's
only the size of a p but if it swells
and becomes tender I immediately know I
need to back off and I need to hit
myself with the remedies that I know
will keep me from getting sick otherwise
it's over so everyone has a check engine
light I'm convinced and I work with
people to discover what your check
engine light is so that you learn to
listen to your body it's interesting and
it's interesting to see how the health
message integrates with the gospel
absolutely it's the it's the right arm
it of the Gospel it is could you give
other doctors some advice as to how to
incorporate the gospel into the work
that they do should they stay in the
hospital should they get out more yes
what I tell people is this the medical
literature is clear 90% of patients
actually desire for their physician to
approach spiritual health with them but
we don't now why that is I'm not really
sure but I'm convinced that we're not
comfortable doing it because if you
become comfortable with it your patient
will become comfortable with it and this
is how I do it I work in the emergency
room so I'm dealing with life
threatening conditions and I'll say
something like well Mrs Smith it appears
you have acute appendicitis and you're
going to be going to the theater right
now but before I send someone to the O I
always like to say a prayer for them
that God would guide the hands of the
surgeon and that there would be no
post-operative infection and there would
be no scarring or complications would
you like me to pray for you
well what's Mr Mr VI I'm afraid that the
EKG shows you're having an acute heart
attack so you'll be going to the angio
Suite right away but before I send
someone for a stent I always like to
pray that God will guide the hands of
the cardiologist that the stent will be
appropriately placed and it will not
clot off again would you like me to say
a prayer for you it's amazing if you're
comfortable with it the patient will be
comfortable with it it's that simple and
the problem is is most of us aren't
comfortable with it because if you're
not praying on your knees in the morning
you can't pray with your patience in the
afternoon no there's a disconnect
absolutely so that's that's great how
how you know the truth and and health
how that how that integrates and how you
can heal someone physically and
spiritually so so what is truth to you I
mean what is what is the definition of
truth I love that question Robert and of
course that question was asked by pilate
he was confronting Jesus and Jesus told
him the truth but pilate says what is
truth but we're told he didn't wait for
the answer because of course Jesus says
I am the way the truth and the life in
John 17 he says Thy word is truth and I
can tell you that as a doctor I'm
encountered with simple truths of
natural law every day right if you smoke
you will get lung cancer yeah if you eat
a high high fat High saturated fat High
animal protein diet you will get cancer
you will get heart disease if you are
overweight you will destroy the joints
in your knees and your hips there is
natural law we're encountered with in
medicine every day but the author of
both spiritual truth and natural law is
the same that's the beauty and God uses
those natural truths to teach us
spiritual Truth for one example God says
in the Ten Commandments something that's
very scary he says I am a jealous God
visiting the iniquities on the fathers
and the sons and the son Sons to the
third and fourth generation but what God
is doing there he is not making a threat
he is only making a statement of fact
yes when you look at three and four
generations cuz we're dealing with the
Commandment on idolatry here right when
you look at three and four generations
that's about 60 to 80 years depending on
how you would calculate
but you know what's interesting in our
genetic code itself there are small
little groups methyl groups little
molecules that sit above the DNA called
epig gen EP these epig gen are
influenced by your lifestyle your diet
your stress level your habits your
thoughts even and those epen will
persist now they found in your genetic
line 60 to 80 years God is just
describing epigenetics to you that is
truth that is how the human genome works
and those epig can turn the good genes
on and turn the bad genes off for you
but remember the promise at the end of
that God says but showing Mercy to a
thousand Generations so even though you
may have been dealt a bad set of genes
perhaps God can take you back a thousand
generations to the original Adam and Eve
to that perfect genetic code and line
that you can claim the lineage of your
father all the way back in the Garden of
Eden as you follow Jesus Christ as your
lord and comes back to health you know
the original diet come to me those who
are heavy laden that's where we get our
peace that's where we get our vitality
and our health exactly and it's
important to search out these things and
not just go with what the first good
speaker says yes you have to make sure
what you're seeing what you're reading
what you're believing is truth and I
think that that's a a very important
point and what I enjoy with our ministry
is something similar there was a a
commercial many years ago called Hair
Club for Men and the guy who was always
giving this the Spiel on look at this we
got this person they got a full head of
hairback but at the end of the
commercial he always said and I'm not
just the president but he grabbed a
picture and he says but I'm also a
client and he showed himself almost
completely bald and so people always
believe you when they can see the truth
lived out in your life and I'm not doing
it from a vanity standpoint but I want
to see people it is possible to be in
your 50s and be strong to be vibrant to
be active because in the Jewish
understanding that was the time of
arrival they even asked Jesus Thou Art
not yet 50 years old and hast thou seen
Abraham they said you don't owe anything
you don't know anything you're not even
50 yet but now I am going to be 50 but I
believe God designed us not just to be
healthy mentally at that age but
physically strong and powerful and a
fitness can be your witness M for to
other people many of my uh many of my
Bible studies have come from the gym
people just can't believe it and then
now I have one of those guys that I
worked out with he's one of the regular
Bible study contacts we have every week
wow it's a it's a good example the world
out there so so thank you for sharing
your short testimony with us us and
showing how we can reach others through
pleasure through our example and through
health and through truth relying on
truth and relying on God that's right it
doesn't matter what we do we can preach
to others that's right great well
you end with prayer for us I yes
yes Lord thank you for this wonderful
opportunity and discussion that we had I
pray that you will be with us but not
just us all the people out there
everyone who's searching for truth
everyone who's witnessing may they all
be led by you and through that may they
glorify your name in Jesus name I pray
amen amen amen amen
[Music]